okay so we're doing something a little
different with this video using AI we
asked legendary entrepreneurs some are
alive some are dead that if you had to
start over with a hundred dollars you
had no Fame and you had to turn it into
a million dollars as quickly as possible
what would you do please note these are
not the actual answers from these
entrepreneurs it's what AI thinks they
would answer I'd love your feedback on
the video let me know if you like it you
want to see more like this you hate it
let me know in the comments below and
enjoy the video
if I took away your Connections in Fame
gave you 100 and asked you to turn it
into one million dollars as quickly as
possible what would you do
Evan I'd first invest that 100 into the
most valuable asset you have yourself
acquire knowledge Master a high demand
skill or find something you're
passionate about that also has Market
potential you don't necessarily need a
formal education for this remember I
dropped out of college but that didn't
stop me
what you need is an insatiable curiosity
and the determination to learn and
improve next identify a problem that
many people face and are willing to pay
to solve the bigger the problem the
better if you can create a solution that
is significantly better or different
from what's already out there you're on
your way
remember Apple was successful because we
didn't just make computers we made
computers that were easier and more
enjoyable to use then create a prototype
it doesn't need to be perfect it just
needs to work well enough to show
potential customers and investors what
you're trying to accomplish
use their feedback to improve your
product and make it something they can't
live without once you have a viable
product start marketing tell everyone
about your product get it in front of as
many people as possible the internet has
made this easier than ever use social
media email marketing content marketing
SEO and any other method you can think
of to spread the word about your product
finally don't be afraid to fail failure
is a part of the process
each failure brings you one step closer
to success just keep moving forward keep
learning keep improving and never give
up
if you follow this advice you won't just
make one million dollar you'll create
something meaningful that makes a real
difference in people's lives and that's
worth far more than any amount of money
first thing Evan I'd go straight into
the garage sale and thrift store hustle
I'd be looking for underpriced items
that I know I can flip online for a
profit
I've shown on my YouTube series Trash
Talk how much potential there is in
flipping items you can easily turn 100
into a few hundred or even a thousand if
you know what to look for next I'd
reinvest that money into higher value
items maybe some rare sneakers
collectible toys or vintage clothing the
goal is to keep flipping keep scaling up
then I'd start creating content I
document every step of the journey on
social media building an audience around
this flip game I'm playing I'd be using
Tick Tock Instagram LinkedIn Twitter
YouTube Every platform possible I'm not
just selling products here I'm selling
the story The Journey
once I have an audience I'd start
monetizing that maybe I'd sell merch
maybe I'd get into affiliate marketing
the important thing is that I'm building
multiple revenue streams once I've built
up a decent amount of capital I'd start
investing in digital assets maybe I'd
buy some nfts or start trading
cryptocurrency these markets are
volatile sure but they also have huge
upside potential finally once I've built
up enough of a nest egg I'd start
investing in startups I'd be looking for
early stage companies with big growth
potential just like I did with Twitter
and Facebook back in the day this is a
longer term play
but it's where the real money is and
that's it that's how I'd go from one
hundred dollars to one million dollars
it's not easy and it's not guaranteed
it's going to take a lot of hard work a
lot of hustle and a bit of luck but I
know it's possible because I've done it
before and if I can do it so can you
here's what I do Evan first off I'd
invest in myself I'd use that 100 to buy
a book on sales or real estate two areas
I know like the back of my hand
knowledge is the one thing nobody can
take away from you second I get a job
any job to create an income stream this
isn't about Pride it's about survival
and growth you can't build wealth
without income every dollar I earn that
isn't necessary for basic survival I'm
setting aside third I'd Leverage The
Power of social media I'd create a
YouTube channel start a blog get active
on LinkedIn Instagram and Facebook I'd
share my journey my knowledge and my
hustle I'd build a personal brand
because in today's world your brand is
your reputation and your reputation is
currency fourth I'd start selling I'd
find a product or service I believe in
and start selling it this could be
affiliate marketing Drop Shipping or
even a physical product the key is to
find something that has high demand and
low supply fifth I'd reinvest every
dollar I make from my sales I'd reinvest
back into my business this is how you
scale don't spend your profits reinvest
them finally I'd get into real estate
once I've saved enough for my sales and
my job I'd get into real estate real
estate is a proven wealth Builder it
provides cash flow tax benefits and
appreciates over time remember this is a
marathon not a Sprint is it's about
consistency and persistence you're not
going to make a million dollars
overnight
but if you stick to the plan stay
disciplined and work hard you'll get
there and when you do you'll be
unstoppable this is what I do Evan I'd
start with that one hundred dollars and
invest it in knowledge because knowledge
is the best investment you can make
I would buy books on entrepreneurship
finance and personal growth
once I've read and absorbed as much as I
could I'd use the remaining money to
invest in a small Venture let's say I
choose a product or service I'm
passionate about I'd start a small
business around it perhaps a pop-up
stand or an online shop depending on the
product or service
I'd pour my heart soul and all my energy
into it I'd offer an exceptional
customer experience and I'd work
tirelessly to grow my customer base
while doing all this I'd continuously
educate myself I'd learn about marketing
about sales about how to scale a
business each step of the way I'd
reinvest the profits back into the
business to fuel its growth
then as my business begins to grow I'd
start networking I'd reach out to other
business owners attend events
participate in online forums and do
everything possible to make connections
within my industry
networking is crucial because it's not
just about what you know but who you
know
it could lead to Partnerships
collaborations or even Investments
finally I'd never stop dreaming big and
setting audacious goals I'd Envision
that one million dollars and work
relentlessly towards it remember success
is a journey not a destination
don't give up when the going gets tough
stay committed stay focused and you'll
get there
so to summarize I'd invest in knowledge
start a small business reinvest my
profits Network and never stop dreaming
big also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
I've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there Evan
my advice would be clear and simple I'd
start by doing what I know best
investing first I would focus on
acquiring knowledge
I go to a public library use the
internet and read as much as I could
about investing economics businesses and
industries
I'd start with the basics books like the
intelligent investor by Benjamin Graham
security analysis by Graham and Dodd and
Common Stocks and uncommon profits by
Philip Fisher
knowledge is the most important
investment you can make and it's free
then I'd use the 100 to buy a used
bicycle and a lawnmower I'd use the
bicycle for transportation in the
lawnmower to start a small lawn mowing
business I'd work hard provide an
excellent service and save every penny I
earned I'd live frugally cutting down on
all non-essential expenses once I'd
saved about 500 I'd start investing in
the stock market
I would apply the principles I learned
from my reading look for undervalued
companies with strong fundamentals and a
competitive Advantage be patient and
don't get swayed by market fluctuations
remember the stock market is a device
for transferring money from the
inpatient to the patient I'd continue
working saving and investing slowly
building up my capital
investing in the stock market is not a
get rich quick scheme it requires time
patience and discipline but with careful
analysis and wise investment decisions
it's possible to achieve substantial
returns over the long term to get to one
million dollars I'd need to reinvest my
earnings and let compound interest do
its magic
as Albert Einstein reportedly said
compound interest is the eighth wonder
of the world he who understands it earns
it he who doesn't pays it so in essence
my plan would be to work save invest and
be patient it might not be the quickest
way to turn 100 into one million dollars
but it's a proven strategy that has
worked for me and countless other
investors always remember it's better to
buy a wonderful company at a fair price
than a fair company at a wonderful price
Evan I would first advise that it is not
money or material possessions that
define success but the pursuit of
knowledge and the betterment of humanity
however I understand the nature of your
question my Approach would revolve
around leveraging my skills and
knowledge to create value here's the
plan first I would invest the 100 in
books and educational resources to
broaden my understanding in a profitable
field such as technology or Finance
knowledge is the most powerful tool and
it is the seed of innovation and
progress next I would use this knowledge
to offer for tutoring or Consulting
Services I have a deep understanding of
physics and Mathematics so I would offer
lessons or consultations in these areas
with each successful session my
reputation would grow allowing me to
increase my rates and clientele as my
income grows I would save and invest
wisely I would study the stock market
and other investment opportunities using
my mathematical abilities to analyze
Trends and make calculated decisions
finally I would use the revenue from my
services and the returns from my
investments to fund my own research or
start a business in a promising field
the key is to create a product or
service that fulfills a need or solves
the problem in a novel way remember this
journey is not simply about making money
but about creating value and
contributing to society
the timeline may vary depending on
various factors but with dedication
discipline and intelligent decision
making one can certainly grow one
hundred dollars into one million dollars
first and foremost Evan understand that
the key to success is self-belief hard
work and resilience if I were in that
situation here's exactly what I would do
identify a need
every successful business starts by
solving a problem look around and
identify a pressing need or desire that
people have which is currently
unfulfilled or inadequately addressed
create a plan
with the problem identified you need to
formulate a business plan this includes
determining the product or service to
meet the need identifying the target
market outlining the sales and marketing
strategy and calculating the startup
costs a well-reasoned plan is the
foundation of any successful Venture
invest in materials take your one
hundred dollars and use it to purchase
materials or tools necessary to start
your business
for instance in my case I started by
selling hair care products you could
start a service-based business that
requires minimal upfront investment
start small and grow
start by selling your product or service
to friends family and acquaintances
use their feedback to refine your
offering
as your business grows reinvest profits
back into the business for expansion
Network even without Famer connections
you can start building a network from
scratch attend local events join trade
organizations and be active on social
media platforms relevant to your
business
networking can help you find customers
partners and mentors
scale up
as your business picks up you can start
thinking about scaling up this could
involve hiring additional staff
expanding your product line or even
franchising your business
remember the key to Rapid growth is
ensuring that every decision you make
contributes positively to your bottom
line
remember turning one hundred dollars
into one million dollars is not a matter
of luck but a combination of smart
decisions hard work and Relentless
perseverance
take one step at a time and never lose
sight of your goal all right I love this
question Evan it's a real Challenge and
I'm always up for a challenge you're
talking to someone who's built an Empire
from the ground up so let's get down to
business first things first with just
one hundred dollars you're not going to
make a million dollars overnight but
with the right strategy you can turn
that 100 into one thousand dollars then
ten thousand dollars and keep going from
there it's all about leveraging what you
have to get what you want I'd start by
investing that one hundred dollars into
something I know and understand in my
case that's real estate now you're
thinking how do you invest 100 into real
estate
well it's not about buying properties at
this stage it's about gaining knowledge
I'd buy books attend seminars anything
to get my hands on valuable information
about the market remember knowledge is
power once I've got a good grasp of the
market I'd go out and find the best
possible deal I'd look for properties
under foreclosure distressed sellers
anything that allows me to get a
property under market value then I'd
negotiate I'm a master negotiator I'd
convince them to let me take over their
mortgage payments and get the deed no
money down it's all about the art of the
deal next I'd work on improving the
property to increase its value you don't
need a lot of money for this a Fresh
coat of paint some new fixtures a bit of
landscaping all these things can
significantly increase the value of a
property then I'd either sell the
property for a profit or rent it out for
a steady income then it's all about
repeating the process
the key is to keep moving forward keep
negotiating keep finding those great
deals and remember always think big
don't be afraid of going after those
Million Dollar Deals if you've done your
homework if you've negotiated well you
can make it happen now don't get me
wrong this isn't going to be easy you're
going to have to work hard you're going
to have to be persistent and you're
going to have to be Fearless
but remember I started with a small loan
and turned it into a multi-billion
Dollar Empire so if I can do it so can
you so that's it that's how I'd turn 100
into one million dollars it's not going
to happen overnight but with the right
strategy the right attitude and a lot of
hard work you can make it happen now go
out there and start building your Empire
first Evan I'd invest in my physical
health and mental toughness
I'd buy a gym membership or some weights
start working out daily and build up my
discipline
you cannot conquer the world if you
cannot conquer yourself next I'd use my
physical strength to earn some initial
capital I would find manual labor jobs
or personal training gigs I did it
before when I first came to America and
I'd do it again
hard work has never scared me it should
not scare you either
with the money I earn I'd invest in
education I'd buy books take online
courses and learn about business
investing and real estate
education gives you the tools to make
smart decisions and to take calculated
risks
once I have a solid foundation of
knowledge I'd start investing I'd start
small perhaps with penny stocks or by
flipping items from garage sales the key
is to buy low sell high and to always
keep learning when I have enough money
I'd move on to real estate
this is where the real money is made I'd
start with a small affordable property
fix it up and rent it out then I'd use
the income from that property to invest
in another one and another one all the
while
I'd be networking
building relationships is key you never
know when an opportunity might come from
a connection you've made this is not
going to be easy nor quick but it is
possible
you just have to have the discipline the
courage and the determination to make it
happen
this is the way I do it and this is the
way you can do it too
remember there are no Shortcuts To
Success it always takes time effort and
hard work Evan I would tell you that the
first thing you need to do is shift your
mindset you are not a person with just
one hundred dollars to your name you are
a person with a million dollar idea and
one hundred dollar seed Capital start
thinking of yourself that way because
that's the first step to making this
happen now let's get practical use that
one hundred dollars to buy a domain name
and hosting for a year you're going to
start a website a Blog a podcast or
whatever medium fits your skills and
passion the key here is to build a
platform where you can share your
expertise your unique point of view your
story and start building an audience
once you have that set up start creating
content be consistent and genuine and
focus on providing value give people a
reason to come back the audience you
build will be the foundation of your
future success then start networking
reach out to other people in your field
offer to write guest posts for their
blogs or appear on their podcasts give
first build relationships this is how
you expand your audience and your
influence next monetize you could write
an ebook or create an online course
maybe you offer consulting services or
start a membership site you could also
use affiliate marketing the point is to
create multiple streams of income this
will start slow but as your audience
grows so will your income remember to
reinvest your profits grow your business
hire help if you need it invest in
better equipment always be looking for
ways to expand and improve the more
value you can offer the more you can
charge now I'm not going to lie to you
this is not a get rich quick scheme this
will take time effort and a lot of hard
work
but if you're dedicated if you're
consistent if you're willing to do what
it takes you can turn that 100 into one
million dollars
and finally remember that success is not
just about making money it's about
making a difference
so whatever you do make sure it's
something you believe in something that
adds value to the world because that's
the kind of success that really matters
now go get them
first Evan I would invest in myself
focusing on learning and honing skills
in an area where I see significant
growth potential and where I can make a
meaningful contribution it could be a
Technology field like AI or data science
or an Emerging Market sector I believe
in the power of knowledge and The
Leverage it provides in any field
secondly I would start small I'd use the
one hundred dollars to create a minimum
viable product MVP or service
this could be anything from a simple
software solution to a Consulting
service depending on the skills I've
chosen to develop the key is to start
with something that requires minimal
initial investment but has potential for
high returns next I'd relentlessly focus
on customer feedback and iterative
Improvement the goal is not just to sell
a product or service but to create
something that people find indispensable
by paying close attention to what
customers want and continuously
improving the product or service to meet
their needs I'd work to build a strong
and loyal customer base once the product
or service has proven to be successful
and profitable I'd look to scale this
could mean expanding to New Markets
adding new features or services or
leveraging Partnerships to reach more
customers and finally I'd reinvest the
profits whether it's investing in
further improvements to the product or
service hiring talented people to help
grow the business or even investing in
other promising startups the key is to
keep the money working to generate more
income remember this isn't an overnight
process building a business takes time
effort and perseverance but with the
right approach and a Relentless focus on
learning improving and scaling it's
entirely possible to turn a small
initial investment into a significant
sum absolutely let's do this Evan
firstly we need to understand that
turning 100 into one million dollars is
a massive task but it's not impossible I
would start by investing that 100 into
learning a high demand skill
it could be software development data
analysis or digital marketing something
that doesn't need a massive investment
to learn and has a high return on time
invested
online courses and free resources are
plenty self-education and continuous
learning have always been key components
of My Success
once I've honed that skill I would start
freelancing or Consulting in that field
this allows for a flexible work
environment where I can work on multiple
projects and get paid well for my
expertise
this also lets me build a professional
network from scratch which is incredibly
valuable while doing this I would live
as frugally as possible to save every
penny the key here is to accumulate and
reinvest not to spend
once I've saved enough I would start a
small business related to the skill I've
learned
by now I'd have enough experience and
Connections in the industry to identify
a problem that needs solving and I'd
build a product or service to solve it
with a unique value proposition and by
delivering exceptional value to the
customers I'd grow this business
alongside I'd also invest in financial
assets like stocks or cryptocurrencies
but only when I have a solid
understanding of them
it's important to remember that
investing isn't gambling it's about
making informed decisions
the journey to one million dollars won't
be easy or quick but with determination
strategic thinking and Relentless
execution it's achievable
video
want to celebrate you most people start
and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to see my
interview with AI Steve Jobs check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there the most powerful way
to address this problem is to help
people develop a growth mindset a growth
mindset encourages individuals to see
challenges as opportunities for growth
and Improvement